[MUSIC PLAYING]
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: Hi,
I'm Maya Kaczorowski,
and we're here KubeCon
EU in Copenhagen.
And I'm here with
Jason Yee from Datadog.
How are you?
JASON YEE: Hey, I'm
doing all right.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: So tell
me what Datadog does.
JASON YEE: Yeah, we're a
SAS-based monitoring platform.
So we help customers collect
their metrics, infrastructure
metrics, application metrics,
traces, so thinking of APM,
and their logs,
all in one place.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI:
And so how do I
use that to look at
my Kubernetes metrics?
JASON YEE: Yeah, so we have
Kubernetes integrations already
built in.
So whether you're running
your Kubernetes in GKE
or if you're running it just
on your own standalone on-prem
stuff, all of that metrics can
be gathered up and sent to us
so you can see it
all in one place.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI:
That's super cool.
JASON YEE: Yeah.
It makes it really
handy for people
that are in that
hybrid cloud situation
where they're just
playing around with,
maybe they need
some stuff on-prem,
maybe they're
migrating to the cloud,
it's really helpful to have
everything in one place
as you're doing that.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: Single pane
of glass, we totally get that.
Anything else you want to talk
about about Datadog and Google?
JASON YEE: We love Google.
Yeah.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: That's
always good to hear.
JASON YEE: It's been really
great to partner with Google
on not only integrations
on technical things,
but also with events
because Google
has a bunch of great events like
Google Cloud Next and Google
IO.
So it's always nice
to be a part of those
and see the Google ecosystem
growing, and having
more people there
who are obviously
adopting container technology,
Kubernetes, things like that.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI:
And so where do
I go to find out more about
running Datadog on GKE?
JASON YEE: Yeah, you can find
out more at DatadogHQ.com.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: Are
you using Kubernetes
to monitor Kubernetes?
JASON YEE: We are.
So a big project
for us in this year
is trying to shift all
of our applications
to be containerized.
It helps us be a little
bit more standardized.
It helps us to roll
out wherever we
need to without
the fear of things
being fragile when they're
in virtual machines
or they're just
actually on servers.
So as we're rolling
out, Kubernetes
is a big plan, or
a big part of that
because it just makes managing
containers so much easier.
So yeah.
We help our customers who are
running Kubernetes monitor
their Kubernetes, but it's also
all running on our Kubernetes.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI:
Turtles all the way down.
JASON YEE: It is.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI:
Thank you so much.
JASON YEE: Thanks.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: And thank you
to all those at home watching
and have fun.
[MUSIC PLAYING]